Okay, so Michael here's some silicone that represents an algorithm
of the sort I just described after the last quiz. So
here's the basic idea, just see if you can picture
this. We have, were in the middle of this process, we
have some data at sometimes, step t, and were simply
going to generate samples that are consistent with that distribution. So,
we're going to shoot our probability distribution is not just something that
gives us a probability but something from which we can sample.
So, generate samples according to P su theta sub T.
Generate a bunch of those samples and now that
we have these samples, we're going to come up
with a new theta. T plus one. And that
theta T plus one is going to be the best samples
that we just generated. So, let's say the top
half. Now, you'll notice that this should actually remind you
of something. Does it remind you of any of
the other randomized algorithms that we've looked at so far?
>> Maybe a little bit like simulated annealing.
>> No. Hm.
>> Because it does, you know, change the probability
of going up. What we're choosing. Oh, we're
choosing different percentile. That's a lot like genetic algorithms.
>> Right, it's exactly like genetic algorithms. Except instead
of having this population that moves from one bit
to other, we generate samples that's like our population.
So, we generate a population here. We pick the
most fit of that population by retaining only those
that are the best ones. And all the stuff
that you said before about, well maybe you don't
want to pick the best ones. Maybe you want to sample
it according to a probability distribution proportional to
the fitness. All those things you talked about before
would apply here, but let's just stick to the
simple case where you, you take the best ones.
And, now that we've got this new population, rather
than using that population again, we estimate a new
distribution that's consistent with those. And then we just
lather, rinse, repeat until we come to some conversions.
>> Okay, so let me just make sure I'm following.
First of all, when you say P sup, you don't
mean the food.
>> I do not, because I do not like pea soup.
>> And you don't mean sup meaning like
the largest possible value of theta, because when
I was hearing p-sup theta, I was, I kept thinking that you mean the best theta.
>> No, soup is short for superscript.
[CROSSTALK] When people say p-sub-i, which means subscript.
>> Oh, yeah, okay, that, that makes sense.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, okay. So now now that's [LAUGH] that's clear. The, this notion
of estimating a probability distribution, I guess that's where it
feels really fuzzy to me. because if you do the
estimate as a kind of, I don't know, sort of
particle filtery kind of thing, where you just keep instances.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then it feels really, a lot like the genetic algorithm.
>> Right. Except, remember, one of the things that
we cared about, a structure. So this structure that we're
maintaining remember this, this complaint that I had that we
weren't somehow keeping track of structure in a nice way?
>> Yeah.
>> Is all going to be hidden inside the how we
represent these probability distributions. That is going to
be the structure that moves from time
step to time step rather than just
the population of points moving from time step
to time step. And I'll, I'll get into some details about that in the very
next slide, I just want to make certain
that you understand. The high level bit here.
>> The high level bit.
>> And the high.
>> Yeah, I mean I am not, I am not
connecting it with theta in the sense of the previous slide.
>> So theta is our threshold, right?
So, basically, we have some distribution. Now, remember what
is P superscript theta? It is you know, it is
a probability distribution that is uniform over all points that
are, have a fitness value that is greater than theta,
greater than or equal to theta. Right. So I
have some distribution here. If I just generate samples from
that distribution then what this means is I'm going to be
generating all the points whose value, whose fitness is at
least as good as theta. And then I'm going to
take from those the set of points that are
much higher than theta, hopefully and use that to
estimate a new distribution. And I'm just going to keep doing
that. And what would should happen is, since I'm
consoling taking the best of those, is that theta over
time will get higher and higher, and higher, and
I'll move from theta min over time, the theta max.
And when I get to theta max, I've converged, and I'm done.
>> I see. So all right, so the theta right, so
I guess I was confused because I, I didn't completely absorb the
second line yet. So that we're updating the theta and it's specifically
going to be tracking the, I'm not sure what the nth percentile is.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Adding the number of samples that we draw.
>> Oh no. I'm sorry. Nth means you
know, 50th percentile or 25th percentile or 75th percentile.
>> So, okay.
So, if you set that to be the median.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is the 50th percentile. Then
what we're doing is we're, we're sampling. We're
taking the top half of what's left. We're
somehow refitting a distribution into that, set of
individuals that were drawn. And repeating in
the sense that now, the fitness of those
individuals, the median should be higher because we're
sampling from kind of a more fit collection.
>> Right. That's exactly right.
>> Okay.
>> So this should work or at least it
should match your intuition it would work if there are, sort of two
things that are true. The first is that we can actually do this estimate.
>> Yeah, that's the part that scares me. Uh-huh.
>> Sure. Well given a finite set of data, can we estimate a probability
distribution. So that's the first thing that sort of had better be true. And the
second thing that needs to be true and this is, I think, a bit
more subtle, is that the probability distribution
for a piece of theta and a probability
distribution for say, piece of theta plus epsilon. That
is a slightly higher value of theta, should be kind of
close. So in other, and what does that mean?
What that means. Is that generating samples from P sub
theta of t should give me samples from P sub theta of t plus 1. So I have to
that, that means that not only do I have
to be able to estimate the distribution, I have to
do a good enough job of estimating
this distribution such that, when I generate samples
from it, I will also generate samples
from the next distribution that I'm looking for.
>> Okay?
>> Okay.
>> So if those things are true. Then, I, I hope,
you can be sort of imagine that you would be able to
move from the part of the space that a theta min,
and eventually get to the part of the space, the theta max.
>> Yeah, it seems like it should climb right up. Yeah, I
agree with that. That's just, assuming
that you could represent these distributions
in between. Again, the picture I have in my head is
an, like a bumpy mountainous landscape. And you put a slice through
it. And, in the beginning, yeah, right. So in the beginning
it's the whole space, and that should be easy to represent. At
the end it's a single point, and that's easy to represent.
But in the middle. Yeah, like that. But in the middle, it's
this sort of crazy, there's a blob, then there's a space, then
there's more blob. Little blob with a hole in it, so like
that might be a much harder distribution to represent.
>> Right, and that's going to turn out to
be an empirical question but as I, as I
hope you'll see in a couple of slides
it tends to work out pretty well in practice.
>> Cool.
>> Okay. And by the way when it doesn't work
out well in practice, there's all these cute tricks that
you can do to make it work out pretty well
in practice, and we'll talk about that towards the end, okay